digamos que hicimos una titulación y
empezamos con 20 mililitros de una
solución 0.500 molar de hcl empezamos
con un ácido fuerte y le agregamos una
solución de base fuerte 0.500 molar de n
h conforme agregamos la base el ph
aumenta y podemos ver el cambio en esta
curva de titulación también conocida
como curva de valoración en donde el ph
se encuentra en el eje g y en el eje x
tenemos el volumen de la base que
agregamos en el inciso a nuestro
objetivo es encontrar el ph de la
solución que teníamos antes de agregar
el hidróxido de sodio es decir a los 0.0
mililitros de base entonces si no hemos
agregado la base lo único que tenemos
presente en la solución es el
ahora sabemos que hcl es un ácido fuerte
y se ioniza al 100% si el hc el dona un
protón al h2o obtenemos h3 o más y la
base conjugada de hcl que es cl - si
empezamos con una concentración 0.500
molar de hcl lo escribiré 0.500 molar
como se ioniza completamente porque es
una base fuerte esta es la misma
concentración que tenemos de lyon y
drone yo así que tenemos una
concentración 0.500 molar de iones y
drones y ya podemos saber cuál es el ph
porque el ph es igual a menos el
logaritmo de la concentración de iones
hidronew usemos la calculadora tenemos
menos logaritmo de la concentración de
iones
qué es 0.500 es igual a cero punto 301
entonces si sustituimos esta
concentración obtenemos un ph igual a
cero punto 301 y podemos encontrar ese
punto en nuestra curva de titulación
justo al inicio en donde tenemos 0.0
mililitros de base el ph está justo
arriba del cero y es en donde empieza la
curva de titulación el ph al inicio es
cero punto 301 muy bien ahora
encontremos otro punto en la curva de
titulación esta vez al agregar 10
mililitros de base entonces aquí están
los 10 mililitros de la base y estamos
buscando este punto cual es el ph
después de agregar 10 mililitros bueno
al parecer es muy cercano a 1
pero vamos a calcularlo sabemos que la
base los iones hidróxido que agregamos
neutraliza en alusiones sidronio
presentes en la solución entonces
primero calculemos cuántos moles de
iones sidronio tenemos presentes ya
sabemos que la concentración de iones
hidronew es 0.500 vamos a escribirlo la
concentración de iones sidronio es 0.500
molar y también sabemos que la
concentración molar es igual a los moles
sobre los litros entonces esto es igual
a los moles de h3 o más sobre los litros
y cuál era el volumen de la solución de
ácido inicial bueno si regresamos al
problema empezamos con 20 mililitros
entonces
20.00 mililitros y vamos a convertirlos
a litros
simplemente movemos el punto decimal
lugares hacia la izquierda 1 2 3 y nos
queda 0.02 litros entonces tenemos 0.02
litros en este vídeo veremos muchos
ceros pero sólo mencionaré por ejemplo
0.02 y no mencionaré todos los ceros
entonces para calcular los moles
simplemente multiplicamos 0.5 x 0.02
entonces esto es igual a 0.01 moles de
h3 o más
estos son los moles de ácido con los que
empezamos y vamos a agregar hidróxido de
sodio que es una base fuerte así que la
concentración del hidróxido de sodio es
la misma concentración de iones
hidróxido porque tenemos n
h - entonces como tenemos una solución
0.500 molar de hidróxido de sodio eso
significa que tenemos una concentración
0.500 molar de iones hidróxido la
concentración de iones hidróxido es
igual a cero punto 500 molar y
nuevamente necesitamos saber cuántos
moles de iones hidróxido tenemos si
nuestro volumen fue de 10 mililitros que
para pasarlo a litros movemos el punto
decimal 3 lugares nos queda 0.01 del
volumen es igual a 0.01 litros entonces
calculamos los moles simplemente
multiplicamos 0.5 x 0.01 y nos queda
0.005 estos son los moles de iones
hidróxido ahora
ya que calculamos los moles del ácido y
de la base veamos la reacción de
neutralización la base que agregamos
neutraliza al ácido que teníamos
presente en la solución así que teníamos
algunos iones hidro neo presentes y
agregamos una base como el ácido don a
un protón a la base sí o h - toma un h
más se forma h2o y si h3o más dona un
protón se forma otra molécula de h2o así
que terminamos con dos moléculas de h2o
aunque en lugar de escribir h tres o más
pueden escribir h más que reacciona con
o h - para producir agua cualquiera de
las dos formas está bien ahora vamos a
sustituir los moles nosotros empezamos
con 0.01 moles de h3 o más
0.01 moles de h3 o más y después
agregamos 0.005 moles de hidróxido 0.005
moles de iones hidróxido ahora todo el
hidróxido que reacciona neutraliza a la
misma cantidad de iones y dromio así que
perdemos todos nuestros iones hidróxido
porque la base reacciona completamente
con el ácido y nos quedan 0 moles de
base si perdemos esa cantidad de
hidróxido también perdemos esa cantidad
de iones sidronio entonces 0.01 menos
0.005 es igual a 0.005 estos son los
moles que nos quedan de iones y drones
neutralizamos la mitad de los iones
hidro neo presentes y aún nos queda la
mitad en solución
veamos cuál es la concentración de iones
hidronew en la solución la concentración
molar de iones hidronew es igual a los
moles sobre los litros
entonces nos queda 0.005 moles de h3 o
más entre cuál será el nuevo volumen
bueno empezamos con 20 mililitros de la
solución ácida y a eso le agregamos 10
mililitros de la base agregamos 10
mililitros así que el nuevo volumen es
igual a 30 mililitros
entonces para calcular la nueva
concentración de iones y drone yo vamos
a usar 30 mililitros que es igual a 0.03
litros 123 entonces entre 0.0 3 litros
usemos la calculadora tenemos 0.005
y 0.03 la concentración de iones
sidronio es igual a 0.17 la nueva
concentración es igual a 0.17 molar y ya
que conocemos la concentración de iones
sidronio podemos calcular el ph entonces
el ph es igual a menos el logaritmo de
la concentración de iones sidronio es
decir menos el logaritmo de 0.17 usemos
la calculadora menos logaritmo de 0.17
es igual a 0.77 el ph es igual a 0.77
ahora sabemos que al agregar 10
mililitros de la base el ph es igual a
0.77 regresemos a la curva de titulación
después de agregar 10 mililitros de la
base
p h es igual a cero punto 77 en el
siguiente vídeo analizaremos esta curva
de titulación y buscaremos más puntos